walk him to this video playing the US
game last game I I always have problems
to read this is Jim probably yeah from
from agrees and we get the Kings Indian
all the grid fault let's see Kings inion
the statistics else I hadn't played in
the fire I think I played at me for
maybe if name he does not have weird I'm
totally sure I played it before but it
does not seem to be the case again try
to play the other back here again let's
see 96 they are probably g5 is right
gaining space and time interesting yeah
if I go night due to do no Queen d2
there probably is 94 maybe just night f3
this should be simple I don't think that
Knight g4 is is so great now maybe you
can do it but yeah yeah you can play
that it's not terribly helpful but also
not bad only thing to avoid is e 583
trapping the night yeah
yeah this is this interesting position I
can play this move this is this is a
tricky move intending age three yeah and
there are other ideas he in fact okay I
can just go for that that's just a good
structure now black and play a six yeah
Black has problems with the c5 point no
I'm threatening a five if he does not do
anything against a five the queenside
will fall apart so yeah okay there five
yeah and now the queenside assists will
be able to totally break down there
should be three night a4m okay night if
for directly or okay I cover you for for
the moment
now over protecting you for I will have
night a four in the end or another way
to attack the poem even before not a
four is good so maybe be three Queen a 3
is also a way to go you really had to
play be six or some some defensive
museum
I don't I don't get it really I really
don't get what he's doing besides a
wicking Everest weakening every square
that there is on the board check 94
Quincy to probably probably this is the
easiest wow he takes it not 94 ok ok now
the bishop on g7 is hmm one of the worst
pieces in recent history and i-94 was
absolutely mandatory
gets tied down to c5 this is one very
serious problem and they have ways to to
open up the position with H for trying
to do that now I can maybe play rook f
aid no
yeah this is winning on the kingside no
just breaking through him you could also
play rugby one before and went on the
queenside at some just a matter of taste
d 6 probably so this sec now on age 60 I
can prepare that a bit yeah queen age
eight mate andy sixx hangs should be too
much
black resigns yeah that that was
strategically speaking really am really
a lot of a lot of strange moves yeah
here you absolutely must prevent if I a
five I mean even this move how it looks
really really bad but you must play it
it's simply mandatory and now there is
no way to defend this pawn properly I
really played it in a very very slow
fashion I mean there are maybe quicker
ways to do it for example Queen B 1 and
B form maybe this is even more forceful
yeah this is for instance the computer
computer line this is this is even
stronger with c5 coming yeah that's a
disaster f 3 f 5 and yeah well I plated
like mentioned in a slow manner but ok
gt5 gives up even more squares check and
here yeah 94 is the absolutely only move
and this is in fact still there are some
practical chances at least why this is
dominating with this night and the
non-existing bishop 207 but still it's
something that needs to be one for
example if I take after eat eggs this is
a totally different story so I shouldn't
shouldn't really capture yeah but he
took on e3 and after that I have the
simple the simple difference Y mc5 is
stork always needing protection and now
we can very easily win on the edge farm
yeah something check like this is the
only continuation that is not the direct
made yeah just made too many m
positional mistakes here to to maintain
a decent position alright thanks for
watching